alexis paul un bon jour
heureux de vous retrouver dans la
matinale de rtl france alors le
mouvement de contestation en guadeloupe
ne s'essouffle pas et voici monsieur le
corps du qui met dans la balance la
question de l'autonomie des en tire est
ce que c'est une réponse adaptée alexis
alors c'est une réponse qui montre le en
même temps un d'un côté on envoie le
gign et le raid l'état doit être fort et
de l'autre côté l'état doit négocier
avec ce projet d'autonomie mis dans la
balance un par le gouvernement qui pose
question finalement est ce que c'est une
réponse adaptée beaucoup de
guadeloupéens antillais vous diront non
pas du tout ici le problème c'est la vie
chère l'explosion du prix du gaz de
l'énergie l'accès à l'eau évidemment le
niveau de pauvreté le niveau de chômage
des jeunes qui est bien au dessus de
celui de la métropole et heavy
l'autonomie ne concerne finalement que
quelques politiciens locaux ou est en
train de montrer que le gouvernement
veut bien négocier mais sur la
négociation de fonds on voit bien que le
problème reste l'obligation vaccinale
décalé au 31 décembre alors que pompiers
et certains syndicats de soignants et
autres souhaiterait lever simplement
cette obligation vaccinale dans ce
territoire et puis la question
l'autonomie pour quoi faire si c'est
pour manquer d'argent si c'est pour
avoir ce taux de chômage et de pauvreté
endémique qui restent énormes donc on
voit bien que c'est une façon de
d'entamer les négociations
mais qui n'est pas forcément la réponse
adaptée à la situation d'urgence que
connaît actuellement la guadeloupe c'est
un cadeau empoisonné ce que ça donne des
idées également aux corses ou à la
nouvelle calédonie est ce que ça risque
pas de réveiller les mouvements
indépendantistes oui alors ces
mouvements existants ils sont déjà bien
réveiller seulement ils se disent mais
attendez pourquoi vous proposez
l'autonomie un territoire qu'il a refusé
en 2003 alors d'une question déjà posée
alors que la corse la demande à cor et à
cri avec des nationalistes qui sont
majoritaires qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui
passe par la tête d' emmanuel macron et
puis on a bien sûr ce référendum en
nouvelle calédonie où pourtant c'était
pas forcément les autonomistes qui était
en tête et qui pourrait changer
totalement la donne du vote qui aura
lieu le 12 décembre donc on voit bien
que emmanuel macron qui se voulait un ce
président jacoba régaliens avec cette
verticalité du pouvoir qui rabâche sans
cesse qu'il ne doit pas y avoir deux
territoires perdus de la république que
la république est partout pareil que
l'état doit être fort est en train
finalement de vendre ou de dilapider le
territoire français avec cette
proposition d'autonomie qui arrive comme
un cheveu sur la soupe sur une situation
qui ne demandait pas ça d'abord d'abord
c'était la prise en compte de la non
vaccination la prise en compte aussi du
niveau de profiter de la vie chère et
puis bien sûr là l'autre crise sanitaire
celle du chlordécone qui a été reconnue
puisque on va enfin reconnaître là le
cancer de la prostate comme une maladie
liée à l'utilisation de ce pesticide qui
a été utilisée longtemps après en
guadeloupe alors qu'il était interdit
ici en métropole donc voilà ce réveil
des indépendantisme et des nationalismes
risque de coûter cher à la république
française et c'est entre le maquereau
qui en sera responsable
alors un ex il le ministre d outre-mer
sébastien lecornu est arrivé hier soir
pourquoi une visite si tardif finalement
alors lui il le disait qu'il fallait
arriver déjà dans un territoire apaisé
ou éviter de donner une surcharge de
travail aux forces de l'ordre pour la
protection du ministre mais quand on a
une crise de cette ampleur là s'est
évidemment ça fait 15 jours qu'on se
demande que fait monsieur lecornu
pourquoi il ne se déplace pas pu
rapidement pour rencontrer les acteurs
sociaux l'intersyndicale mais aussi voir
ce qu'il se passe plutôt que de dire on
en voit d'abord la police et puis
j'arrive après alors il ya dans cette
visite évidemment de la politique
politicienne puisque sébastien lecornu a
une autre ambition après celle d'avoir
été ministre des outre mer c'est de
devenir le directeur de campagne du
candidat macron donc au niveau de la
macro ni de tout le monde le regarde en
disant eh bien voilà on va voir comment
il se débrouille avec ce dossier brûlant
qu'est la guadeloupe puisqu'il est seul
en scène à aller là bas gérald darmanin
lui était à calais pour ce qui est des
affaires sociales personne de la
compagne donc il est vraiment seul pour
répondre à la crise sociale est
clairement c'est aussi un choix du
président de le mettre face à ses
responsabilités de voir comment il va
s'en sortir en tant que ministre et en
tant que seul représentant du
gouvernement dans cette crise majeure
merci beaucoup
avec 6 l'édito politique des actifs
poulin a retrouvé sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est tous les lundis matin dans
la matinale sur rtl france